let me just say one thing about this
flame outfit that everyone wants to talk
about
Kardashian has something to say to all
the haters who didn't exactly find a
particular fit
everyone is so fickle the tea was piping
hot on the latest episode of who is the
Kardashians specifically the end credits
when the reality star addressed this
look that she rocked claiming that her
ex Kanye West's fans destroyed her on
the internet let me just say one thing
about this flame outfit that everyone
wants to talk about and on the internet
destroyed me and was like haha this is
what she gets you know not being with
Kanye finally one look she dresses
herself the Kanye outfits must have ran
out the t is this was one of the outfits
he styled and picked out wait
did you hear that I think that was the
sound of a mic dropping if you guys knew
that and if we were together you guys
would think it was the coolest outfit in
the world everyone is so fickle Kim
filed for divorce from yay in February
2021 but she's always been candid about
his influence on her style over the
years I would always stress out about
big events like this and what would I
wear and the last minute part of it and
so he kind of filled it up and got me a
few really nice Couture pieces so that I
wouldn't stress out like that but the
rappers fans aren't the only ones
critiquing her fashion that's what
Connie texts me no white glasses
better and make security wear black
gloves the orange look made me so mad
would have went to jail before I went
out in that last month on the Family's
hit reality show the skims found a
Reddit text she received from her ex
while she was in Milan for the Prada
fashion show in February and safe to say
he wasn't loving Kim's looks while we're
here in Milan Kanye has the kids at home
and he can't help himself and last
season Kim revealed one of the not so
nice things he had to say about her
style amid their split he told me my
career is over and then he showed me a
picture of Marge Simpson wearing
something similar Kim was referring to
this outfit she rocked while being
honored at wsj Magazine's innovator
Awards last October and Marge Simpson
well yeah it's exactly who you're
thinking The Simpsons family matriarch
well it doesn't matter how you feel
inside you know it's what shows up on
the surface accounts that's what my
mother taught me it is what it is at the
time the reality star publicly praised
Kanye for his impact on her fashion
sense explaining quote Kanye will always
be the most inspirational person to me
and since all that Kim's been venturing
out on her own and finding her own style
fashion has always been something that
I've always been really into but I've
never been like the creative I
definitely see what I like but I've
never really been like the Visionary I
always just trusted in him but it's not
just about clothes that was like the
last thing we had really in common I was
always like the Kardashians with my
sisters and then I was like Kim yay like
who is Kim K that is the jump how do I
get there when without Kanye
[Music]